[Musik]
ein tropisches naturparadies im
indischen ozean
das sind die seychellen hier gibt es
viele mantarochen denn hier finden sie
nahezu perfekte bedingungen und
wunderschön wie sie schneller weideli
ist biologin und schreibt ihre
doktorarbeit über junghaie unterstützt
wird sie von der schweizer stiftung save
our seeds die hier auch ein manta
projekt betreibt michael scholl ist der
direktor der stiftung zu sammeln tauchen
sie ab um zu prüfen wie es um die
anmutigen meerestiere steht
ornella macht berisha fotos vom bauch
der tiere denn jedes exemplar hat eine
individuelle auszeichnung die bilder
helfen der wiedererkennung und sind
wichtig um die wanderung der tiere
nachzuvollziehen
[Musik]
die tiere sind imposant und die
spannweite der brustflossen kann bis zu
sieben meter betragen die friedlichen
giganten ernähren sich vor allem von
plankton dass sie in küstennähe bei fans
und korallenriffen finden
[Musik]
berisha buch vorteile
wenn wir unter wasser sind die so
[Musik]
elegant und die ganze saison so schwer
sein eine ganze ist auf dem flyer mit
dem antrag und es gibt auch vorher
gesehen
das in den ozeanen weltweit 86 millionen
tonnen plastik schwimmen ist für die
forscherin alarmierend denn für die
meeresbewohner kann es zu einer
tödlichen mahlzeit werden
[Musik]
in indonesien ist umwelt lehrer jonas
müller unterwegs zur insel arbeit
ja
auch hier fast 9000 kilometer von den
seychellen entfernt sorgen mantarochen
für große begeisterung
[Musik]
doch eigentlich hat jonas heute etwas
ganz anderes im sinn
der gebürtige planer jonas müller lebt
seit 2005 zehn reiter am cut erst
arbeitete er für eine ngo und lernte
indonesisch dann eröffnete er seine
eigene umweltschule eine einheimische
familie schloss ihn ins herz und half
dass er bald teil der dorfgemeinschaft
wurde immer man barack obama begrüßt
jonas er hat sich an der hand verletzten
ist schwer geworden
hier hat er sich wehgetan dass wer hat
sich im fahrzeug verbrannt dass das
jüngste kind der familie nach ihm
benannt wurde pariert jonas bist du und
du
123 und ausgegangen
disco trinker ehemals kaiser ist doch
dass mit dem einst kaiser ist doch trotz
nach einer schlafdauer und so quasi in
ein produkt
[Musik]
hier ist jonas jederzeit willkommen
es ist schön jonas als weiteren sohn zu
haben
er hilft mir wenn ich etwas brauche und
die schau ein wenig zu ihm
wir sind absolut das war mein bock gab
es kaum möglich so sagen wissen
das haben auch wurde ich ziemlich zahmer
geschäftsführer
die verletzung wird bald wieder zum
thema werden
denn jonas leibliche eltern aus der
schweiz sind auf dem weg hierher
das engadin liegt unter einer
schneedecke beim silbersee liegt die
temperatur bei kühlen 2 grad
das perfekte wetter zum eistauchen
finden adelig uhr und seine tochter
ich bin schon viel mist aufhören doch
dann ja macht jetzt ist auf kurs
der erfahrene taucher instruktor weiß
eistauchen macht man nur in der gruppe
alleine wäre es zu riskant
[Musik]
unter anderem in zürich den alle nur
nennen liebt alle tauch sportarten darum
kennt er sämtliche tricks um der
klirrenden kälte zu trotzen kann mit dem
vorfeld die herrschen kälte schützen
besser - opex geschult
das sind spezielle hartmann graf für die
den wärme für fünf stunden can't give me
up und dann konkrete schützen besser
wenn ich doch dann die zwei kritiken was
bei einer 20 minuten im wasser ihnen das
wird dann schon mit dem rad halten
tauchen im eiswasser für die meisten
eine abschreckende vorstellung
tochter tanja lebt warme gewässer wärme
platz helfen er sich an die welt der
kalt taucher zu gewöhnen
[Musik]
danke
das wieder so gut dass man die herrliche
natürlich da zwischen den es intern
trinkt wasser nach oben ihnen und
bereitet sich und da gehört man schnell
wieder zum kostenlosen und der sich
jetzt mal die wahrheit ist nicht so
einfach
bocholt auch neue serie und das loch
gefunden und danach das braucht also
sicherheitsleute lied alleine sympathie
eine szene alles namen zu nennen
[Musik]
in writer amt bei west papua hat jonas
seine eltern abgeholt
die planer walti und susi müller waren
fast drei tage unterwegs um ihren sohn
zu besuchen
als sponsoren forderten
wer hier an
dann kommen sie in sabin 3 an ein
kleines dorf das seit zwei jahren die
wahlheimat von jonas ist primarlehrer
walti entdeckte skandale herumlungert
die eltern freuen sich auf die
gemeinsamen tage mit ihrem sohn während
des jahres bekommen
den 28 jährigen nur per skype zu gesicht
das ist ganz klar
und natürlich jedes mal als highlight
ist ein trinker mit der raumnot wie anno
mit braucht das tier überlebte bis zu
erhöhen
sie sehen und ihnen dort passiert sicher
dass er das heißt
[Musik]
eines der seltenen baum kängurus auch
zwischen den blättern hervor
fast scheint es als ob es den besuch aus
näfels willkommen heißen wolle
[Musik]
mai ist die hauptinsel der seychellen
mitten im indischen ozean
die forscherin ornella weideli streift
mit dem schweizer wissenschaftler karl
fleischmann und seinem kollegen durch
einen mangrovenwald in diesem
geschützten gebiet gibt es zahlreiche
junghaie es ist futterplatz und
kinderstube für junge haie und andere
fische bbh wachsen hier auf und finden
futter leben zitronen titel holen
möglich ja schon gesehen nein sie zeigen
sich selten tagsüber es ist jetzt sehr
trüb normalerweise ist es klar ja viel
klarer
[Musik]
terence wellen engagiert sich seit
vielen jahren für dieses gebiet denn
mangroven sind ein wichtiger
küstenschutz für mensch und tier
aber sie wurden jahrelang rücksichtslos
gerodet nun koordiniert welt die
wiederaufforstung dieser wälder
[Musik]
jungherr jörg sannitz eschen mauren
große das rund das land wo man groß sehr
wichtige rolle spiele wie hier die
gleiche labour schadet 40 stück wurde
man natürlich aktie und in normaler
tourist durch die überbauung von
christen streifen wurden diese wichtigen
ökosysteme und klima gasspeicher
zerstört weltweit
nun soll im mai die wiederaufforstung
den tieren ihren lebensraum zurückgeben
[Musik]
der regen wird hier von jahr zu jahr
heftiger
davon gehen allgemein akzeptierte
klimamodelle aus dennoch gibt es weniger
frischwasser wegen der globalen
klimaerwärmung verdunsten pflanzen mehr
und haben einen höheren wasserbedarf
auch der tourismus schadet der umwelt
arena ist konsequenterweise vegetarierin
konsum touristisch konsumiert und das
ist ein großes problem ist
und um dem tourismus im blick
[Musik]
im indonesischen dorf sabin 3 soll für
die gemeinsame mahlzeit alles perfekt
sein
jonas und seine eltern haben sich viel
zu erzählen
auf dem speiseplan stehen reis nudeln
gemüse und der wein wird für später
aufgehoben
die eltern unterstützen jonas und seine
umwelt projekt auch wenn er dafür seine
karriere als betriebsökonom in der
schweiz aufgegeben hat aus erfahrung
wissen sie wenn ihr sohn sich etwas in
den kopf gesetzt hat gibt es nichts dass
ihn aufhält ist natürlich genau gewusst
hat was macht zwei jahre grund sei mit
dem postauto wie die adoptiv mama macht
sich auch seine mutter sorgen wegen der
verletzung an jonas fuß wie damals als
jonas von einem blauring octopus
gebissen wurde und den lebensgefahr war
in der schweiz wurde ihm später eine
zähe amputiert
und ich sage ich hallo marianne p habe
denke ich
so gibt es im rest zahlt und südkorea
die eltern haben das unkonventionelle
leben ihres sohnes schon lange
akzeptiert dass walter müller will in
zwei jahren in pension gehen dann kann
jonas mit tatkräftiger unterstützung
rechnen
[Musik]
auf mahé der hauptinsel der seychellen
begleitet ornella weideli den ehemaligen
eth dozenten karl fleischmann
er koordiniert für die lokale
universität diverse waldprojekte
eine vermutlich eingeschleppte
schlingpflanze trägt zur wasserknappheit
auf der insel bei denn ihr wasserbedarf
ist extrem hoch und ist unglaublich dass
eine pflanze zum landschaftsprägenden
element der tore
wir haben dann darf das ist der mann der
eigentlich mehr also die letzten tage
kaum weniger schlau und trotzdem ist man
vom trinkwasser trinkwasser tätig ist
ist kriegen sie bewusst es ist schwierig
rücktritt mit oder und und sehr viel zu
wenig wissen von bord für die ist das
einfach schön gehen oder aber gesagt
dass es bereits in dem karl fleischmann
bekämpft die eindringlinge mit studenten
tausch der eingeschleppte pflanzen gegen
einheimische aus
merkel das ist dass es ist und das ist
eigentlich genau das oder wochen merke
dass ich umso weniger invasive pflanzen
vor ihnen und das bist wunderschön sich
eigentlich mahagoni plant auch was mir
sehr schön zäh wie der wald wie wir
übernimmt wird natürlich nativ alten dem
ist pall mall gefallen und was nur darf
nicht wieder
[Musik]
karl fleischmann und ornella weideli
zwei schweizer die sich mit viel
herzblut für die wasserwelten der
seychellen engagieren beide auf ihre
weise
[Musik]
von den tropen zum polarkreis hier im
osten grönlands macht sich eine
expedition zum aufbruch bereit
intersil abholt ein schneescooter den
schweizer multimedia journalisten robert
hansen ab die temperatur liegt um den
nullpunkt für robert ist das t shirt
wetter auf dem zugefrorenen fjord will
er in eisigen gewässer abtauchen kann
tauchen ist eine große passion des 52
jährigen
[Musik]
doch vor dem eisigen abenteuer wartet
viel arbeit auf ihn eigentlich
beschreibt ziemlich viel schnee und das
mache ich den heimischen äckern und
jetzt mache ist dass wir im moment
gerade so als ich also absolut der
notebook auch tatsächlich natürlich
jetzt wieder rund
aber zuerst muss nochmal danach und
gotthard ist und schnell wachsen
[Musik]
aber auch die kollegen tun sich schwer
mit der fast meter die eisdecke das
problem ist dass man überhaupt das loch
linie des stücks sorgen und die
verbrechen war mir einfach zu machen
sondern überhaupt das lachen wenn man
dieses laster der firma ja dass das
objekt zu nehmen
[Musik]
reiter amt ist ein weltweit bekannter
hotspot für taucher und schnorchler
ja
[Musik]
jonas will seinen eltern die schönheit
der indonesischen unterwasserwelt zeigen
[Musik]
so etwas darf im jonastal großen haben
mit der unterwasserwelt aus davos segel
das ist ja unglaublich also dann muss
man ja verstehen
in der schweiz zieht es die
bibliothekarin in die berge die sind ihr
element machen wir mit den jungs ein
rennen alle zu mir wartet ihr 12 23
[Gelächter]
gratuliere
123 ausgehebelt
[Musik]
reiter amt ist eines der artenreichsten
meeresgebiete der erde und nicht zuletzt
darum ein paradies für mensch und fisch
[Musik]
die stille der weiten landschaft
grönlands wird einzig von einem
monotonen geräusch durchbrochen und sei
noch probier mal eine andere note zum
lutherweg rassistisch dafür dass man
nachher könne vielleicht hauptstadt auch
heute ist der tag
[Musik]
ja das ist doch genauso dick ich glaube
wenn wir das so dann will es mir doch
was macht in der hand wenn man das
wasser kann ist völlig
[Musik]
anders als in grönland wird am silbersee
nicht lange gefackelt
die uhr und seine tochter staunen wie
routiniert der langjährige
polizeitaucher us grigoli das
einstiegsloch öffnet
[Musik]
wo sind jetzt arena
rechte gruppen sorgsam ist nach rom
so haben es noch verschiedene schichten
zweimal
alles in allem geht doch um fast 40
zentimeter kiesschicht ist nicht sehr
viel wie ein schwarzer 70 zentimeter so
auch die und anja machen den bodycheck
zuletzt ist der praktische teil
ja ich sage ich kein großer unterschied
sonys ecke landet 20 unterschiedlich
sein können und im grund aber mit liebe
und respekt ist faszination und die ist
die dexcel die strukturen wie sie ist
gewachsen ist
jeder taucher muss sich an seilen so
findet er zurück zum einstiegsloch und
kennzeichen geben wenn er in
schwierigkeiten gerät ganz der vater
taucht tanja mutig als erster ab es ist
ihre premiere
noch weiß sie nicht was sie unter dem
eis erwartet
[Musik]
do
wir sind zurück in der magischen
unterwasserwelt von reiter am cut es ist
ein ort mit der weltweit größten
biodiversität jonas müller will
mithelfen diese zu erhalten
susi müller hat ihre anfängliche skepsis
überwunden und wird mit einem
einzigartigen einblick belohnt
[Musik]
sowohl vorne los
das wunderschöne große
die unterwasserbilder werden die eltern
wohl auch zu hause in näfels noch lange
begleiten
[Musik]
auf dem zugefrorenen viert im osten
grönlands wird den eistauchen nichts
geschenkt noch immer ist handarbeit
angesagt
salzwasser würde eine motorsäge sofort
zerstören
ja wir sind jetzt hier stehen am
sachverstand und sagen na ja ich habe
schon vorgestellt das ist zehn jahre
strecken wird das rheinwasser bergsee
passieren dass man muss sagen aber das
streben mit 80 mal 80 zentimeter dick
sie ist es muss zu sagen also endlich
gerät das tonnenschwere eis in bewegung
es ist vollbracht der eingang zur
eisigen unterwasserwelt ist offen
eis strukturen mit eingeschlossenen
luftblasen so sieht die welt unter
wasser
im oberengadiner silbersee aus das licht
das durch das eis schimmert verleiht der
szenerie etwas entrücktes dann stellt ag
die eiswelt auf den kopf was einfach
aussieht kann nur ein geübter taucher
er wird den jährige surfer zu kommen das
allein erklärt jörg pastoor ahlen
[Musik]
patchwork mit alleine
doch auch in dieser verfahrenen
situation bewahrt der erfahrene taucher
[Musik]
vater und tochter haben den ersten
gemeinsamen eis tauchgang unbeschadet
überstanden und ist hier richtig
die fläche entlang vor allem mit ruft
hat super leistung und der temperatur
dort gute mischung aus mir nur was ich
zumindest der vater stolz ist ag
anzumerken
sie sehen ich gehe sehr krank sagt sie
hat ruhig taucht sehr ruhig stufe der
lunge hat man hat nicht nur für die ist
es unruhig schläft
wir können applaus also vor dem habe ich
sehr stolz für ihn die tochter dass das
so geklappt hat
tanja gratulieren hat sich die
baumbestandenen ist auch daran dass sich
vor und ich weiß noch nicht ein bisschen
rauber und umfang sowie letzte programm
die heimelf stellen
hier verlassen mira die und tanja dass
er seine leidenschaft für wasserwelten
an seiner tochter weitergeben konnte ist
eine große genugtuung nach stundenlangem
eis segen kann robert hanssen endlich in
arktische gewässer abtauen über wasser
ist es null grad unter wasser -3 grad
selbst für hartgesottene ist das eine
herausforderung
sonnenstrahlen dringen durch das eisloch
jetzt am ende des winters ist die sicht
besonders gut
sie ist bis zu 40 meter weit
robert hanssen scheint entrückt in
dieser ganz eigenen welt
mit seiner kamera fotografiert er das
leben unter wasser paar begriffe und
kleine garnelen bunte anemonen die im
licht der tauch lampen erstrahlen ein
gar nicht teuer skorpion fisch und
blüten artige schnecken sind zu
entdecken
[Musik]
für robert heben sich zeit und raum hier
unten auf
[Musik]
doch nach einer stunde zwingt die kälte
robert zum auftauchen
[Musik]
traumhafte
und wie schneiden wir noch sturm schauen
wir doch die hand
aber das macht ja auch nicht zu
verwischen
in der letzten folge von wasserwelten
erlebt robert hansen sein ganz
persönliches highlight das ist doch
gültigkeit
jonas müller zeigt seinen schülern die
wunderbare welt der man das zumindest
sagt jetzt keine mehr
und auf den seychellen hilft ohne
weideli mit wasserschildkröten zu
schützen
[Musik]